Hi everybody.
My name is serine and I'm going to be
talking about how to use neural networks
to model sequences.
In the previous lecture you saw how you
could use a neural network to model a
Dataset of many examples.
The difference with sequences is that
each example consists of multiple data
points.
There can be a variable number of these
data points per example,
and the data points can depend on each
other in complicated ways.
So a sequence could be something like a
sentence,
like this morning I took the dog for a
walk.
This is one example,
but it consists of multiple words and
the words depend on each other.
Another example would be something like
a medical record one medical record
would be one example,
but it consists of many measurements.
Another example would be something like
a speech wave form where this one wave
form as an example,
but again it consists of many,
many measurements.
You've probably encountered sequence
modeling tasks in your everyday life,
especially if you've used things like
google translate Alexa or Siri tasks
like machine translation and question
answering are all sequenced modeling
tasks.
And the state of the art in these tasks
is mostly deep learning based.
Another interesting example I saw
recently was this self parking car by
Audi.
When you think about it,
parking is also a sequence modeling task
because parking is just a sequence of
movements and the next movement depends
on all the previous movements.
Um,
you can watch the rest of this video,
uh,
online.
Okay,
so a sequence modeling problem.
Now I'm just going to walk through a
sequence modeling problem to kind of
motivate why we need a different
framework for specifically for modeling
sequences and what we should be looking
for in that framework.
Okay,
so the problem is predicting the next
word.
Given these words,
we want to predict what comes next.
The first problem we run into is that
machine learning models that are not
explicitly designed to deal with
sequences take as input a fixed length
factor.
Think back to the feed forward neural
network.
From the first lecture that Alexander
introduced,
we have to specify the size of the input
right at the outset.
We can't sometimes feed in a vector of
length.
10 other times feed into elector a
vector of length 20 it has to be fixed
line.
So this is kind of an issue with
sequences because sometimes we might
have seen 10 words and we want to
predict the next word.
Sometimes we might've seen forwards and
we want to predict the next word,
so we have to get that variable length
input into a fixed length vector.
One simple way to do this would be to
just cut off the vectors.
So say,
okay,
we're going to just take a fixed window,
forced the specter to be fixed length by
only considering the previous two words,
no matter where we're making the
prediction.
We'll just take the previous two words
and then try to predict the next word.
Now we can represent these two words as
a fixed length vector by creating a
larger vector and then allocating space
in it for the first word.
And for the second word,
we have a fixed length vector.
Now,
no matter what,
two words we're using and we can feed
this into a machine learning model like
a feed forward neural network or a
logistic regression or any other model
and try to make a prediction.
One thing you might be noticing here is
that by using this fixed window,
we're giving ourselves a very limited
history.
We're trying to predict the word walk.
Having only seen the words for and a,
this is almost impossible,
put differently.
It's really hard to model longterm
dependencies to see this clearly.
Consider the word in,
sorry,
consider the sentence in France.
I had a great time and I learned some of
the blank language.
We're trying to predict the word in the
blank.
I knew it was French,
but that's because I looked very far
back at the word France that appeared in
the beginning of the sentence.
If we were only looking at the past two
words or the past three words or even
the past five words,
it will be really hard to guess the word
in that blank.
So we don't want to limit ourselves so
much.
We want to ideally use all of the
information that we have and the
sequence,
but we also need a fixed length vector.
So one way we could do this is by using
the entire sequence,
but representing it as a set of counts
in language.
This representation is also known as a
bag of words.
All this is is a vector in which each
slot represents a word and the number in
that slot represents the number of times
that that word occurs in the sentence.
So here,
the second slot represents the word this
and there's a one because this appears
once in the sentence.
Now we have fixed length factor.
No matter how many words we have,
the vector will always be the same size
as the council just be different.
We can feed this into a machine learning
model and try to make a prediction.
The problem you may be noticing here is
that we're losing all of the sequential
information.
These counts don't preserve any order
that we had in the sequence to see why
this is really bad.
Consider these two sentences.
The food was good,
not bad at all versus the food was bad.
Not good at all.
These are completely opposite sentences,
but their bag of words representation
would be exactly the same because they
contain the same set of words.
So by representing our sentence as
counts,
we're losing all of the sequential
information,
which is really important because we're
trying to model sequences.
Okay,
so what do we know?
Now we want to preserve order in the
sequence,
but we also don't want to cut it off to
um,
to a very short length.
You might be saying,
well,
why don't we just use a really big fixed
window?
Before we were having issues because we
were just using a fixed window of size
to what if we extended that to be a
fixed window of size seven.
And we think that by looking at seven
words,
we can get most of the context that we
need.
Well,
yeah,
okay,
we can do that.
Now we have another fixed length vector
just like before.
It's bigger,
but it's still fixed length.
We have allocated space for each of the
seven words.
We can feed this into a model and try to
make a prediction.
The problem here is that I consider this
in the scenario where we're feeding this
input factor into a feed forward neural
network.
Each of those inputs,
each of those ones and zeroes has a
separate weight connecting it to the
network.
If we see the words this morning at the
beginning of the sentence,
very,
very commonly the network,
we'll learn that this morning represents
a time where a setting,
if this morning then appears at the end
of the sentence,
we'll have a lot of trouble recognizing
that because the weights at the end of
the vector never saw that phrase before
and the weights from the beginning of
the vector and not being shared with the
end.
In other words,
things we learn about the sequence won't
transfer if they appear at different
points in the sequence because we're not
sharing any parameters.
All right,
so you kind of see all the problems that
arise with sequences now and why we need
a different framework.
Specifically,
we want to be able to deal with variable
length sequences.
We want to maintain sequence orders so
we can keep all of that sequential
control information.
We want to keep track of longer term
dependencies rather than cutting it off
too short and we want to be able to
share parameters across the sequence so
we don't have to relearn things across
the sequence because this is a class
about deep learning.
I'm going to talk about how to address
these problems with neural networks,
but no,
that time series modeling and sequential
modeling is a very active field in
machine learning and,
and it has been and there are lots of
other machine learning methods that have
been developed to deal with these
problems.
But for now all talk about recurrent
neural networks.
Okay.
So a recurrent neural network is
architected in the same way as a normal
neural network.
We have some inputs,
we have some hidden layers and we have
some outputs.
The only difference is that each hitting
unit is doing a slightly different
functions.
So let's take a look at this one hidden
unit to see exactly what it's doing.
Ever current hidden unit computes a
function of an input and it's own.
Previous output it's own previous output
is also known as the cell state.
And in the diagram it's denoted by s the
subscript is the time timestamp.
So at the very first time stuff t equals
zero.
The recurrent current unit computes a
function of the input at t equals zero
and of its initial state.
Similarly at the next time stop,
it computes a function of the new input
and it's previous cell state.
If you look at the function at the
bottom,
the function to compute as to you'll see
it's really similar to the function for
that a hidden unit in a feed forward
network,
um,
computes.
The only difference is that we're adding
in an additional term to incorporate its
own previous state.
Common way of viewing recurrent neural
networks is by unfolding them across
time.
So this is the same hidden unit at
different points in time.
Here you can see that at every point in
time it takes us input it's own previous
state and the new input at that time
step.
One thing to notice here is that
throughout the sequence we're using the
same weight matrices.
W and u.
This solves our problem,
a parameter sharing.
We don't have new parameters for every
point in the sequence.
Once we learned something,
it'll can apply at any point in the
sequence.
This also helps us deal with variable
lengths sequences because we're not pre
specifying the length of the sequence.
We don't have separate parameters for
every point in the sequence.
So in some cases we can unroll this rnn
to four time steps and other cases we
can unroll it to 10 times steps.
Yeah.
Final thing to notice is that Essa,
Ben,
the cell state at time n can contain
information from all of the past time
steps.
Notice that each cell state is a
function of the previous cell state,
which is the function which is a
function of the previous cell state and
so on.
So this kind of solves our issue of
longterm dependencies because at a time
step,
very far in the future that sal state
encompasses information about all of the
previous cell states.
All right,
so now that you kind of understand what
a recurrent neural network is,
and just to clarify,
actually shown you one hitting unit in
the previous slide,
but in a full network you would have
many,
many of those hidden units and even many
layers of many hidden units.
So now we can talk about how you would
train a recurrent neural network.
It's really similar to how you train a
normal neuro network.
It's backpropagation.
There's just an additional time
dementia.
As a reminder in backpropagation,
we want to find the parameters that
minimize some loss function.
The way that we do this is by first
taking the derivative of the loss with
respect to each of the parameters and
then shifting the parameters in the
opposite direction in order to try and
minimize the loss.
This process is called gradient descent.
So one difference with rns is that we
have many time steps so we can produce
an output at every time step because we
have an output at every time step.
We can have a loss at every time step
rather than just one single loss of fee
end.
Because,
and the way that we deal with this is
pretty simple.
The total loss is just the sum of the
losses that every time stuff.
Similarly,
the total gradient is just the sum of
the gradients at every time step.
So we can try this out by walking
through this gradient computation for a
single parameter.
W W is the weight matrix that we're
multiplying by our inputs.
We know that the total loss,
the the total gradient,
so the derivative of loss with respect
to will be the sum of the gradients at
every time step.
So for now we can focus on a single time
step knowing that at the end we would do
this for each of the time steps and then
sum them up to get the total gradient.
So let's take time.
Step two,
we can solve this gradient using the
chain rule.
So the derivative of the loss with
respect to w is the derivative of the
loss with respect to the output,
the derivative of the output with
respect to the south state at time two
and then the derivative of the cell
state.
With respect to w.
So this seems fine,
but let's take a closer look at this
last term.
You'll notice that as to also depends on
s one and s one also depends on w.
So we can't just leave that last term as
a constant.
We actually have to expand it out
farther.
Okay.
So how do we expand this out farther?
What we really want to know is how
exactly does the cell state at time step
to depend on w?
Well it depends directly on w because it
feeds right in.
We also saw that as two depends on s one
which depends on w and you can also see
that s two depends on ss zero,
which also depends on w in other words.
And here I'm just writing it as a
summation and those uh,
the,
the sun that you saw on the previous
slide as a summation form and you can
see that the last two terms are
basically summing the contributions of w
in previous time stops to the error at
time.
Step t,
this is key to how we model longer term
dependencies.
This gradient is how we shift our
parameters and our parameters.
Define our network by shifting our
parameters such that they include
contributions to the error from past
time stops there,
shifted to model longer term
dependencies.
And here I'm just writing it as a
general,
some not just for time stuff too.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
So this is basically the process of
backpropagation to tap through time.
You would do this for every parameter in
your network and then use that in the
process of gradient descent.
Yeah.
In practice,
rns are a bit difficult to train,
so I kind of want to go through why that
is and um,
what some ways,
some ways that we can address these
issues.
So let's go back to the summation.
As a reminder,
this is the derivative of the loss with
respect to w and this is what we would
use to shift our parameters.
W The last two terms are considering the
air of wwe at all of the previous time
steps.
Let's take a look at this one term.
This is how we,
this is the derivative of the cell state
at time.
Step two,
with respect to each of the cell states.
Okay.
You might notice that this itself is
also a chain rule because as two depends
on s one and s one depends on a zero.
We can expand this out farther.
This is just for the derivative of s two
with respect to a zero but what if we
were looking at a time step very far in
the future like time step n that term
would expand into a product of an terms
and okay,
you might be thinking so what?
Well as notice that as the gap between
time stops gets bigger and bigger,
this product in the gradient gets longer
and longer and if we look at each of
these terms,
what,
what are each of these terms?
They all kind of take the same form.
It's the derivative of a cell state with
respect to the previous cell state.
That term can be written like this and
the actual form that actual formula
isn't that important.
Just notice that it's a product of two
terms,
ws and F primes.
W's are our weight matrices.
These are sampled mostly from a standard
normal distribution,
so most of the terms will be less than
one f prime is the derivative of our
activation function.
If we use an activation function such as
the hyperbolic tangent or a sigmoid f,
prime will always be less than one.
Okay.
In other words,
we're multiplying a lot of small numbers
together in this product.
Okay,
so what does this mean?
Basically it recall that this product is
how we're adding the gradient from
future time steps to the gradient.
Sorry.
How we're adding the gradient from
pastime steps to the gradient at a
future time stuff.
Okay.
What's happening then is that errors due
to further and further back time stops
have increasingly smaller gradients
because that product for further back
time stops will be longer and since the
numbers are all decimals,
there'll be,
it will be,
it will.
It will become increasingly smaller.
What does,
what this ends up meaning at a high
level is that our parameters will become
biased to capture a shorter term
dependencies.
The errors that arise from further and
further back time stops will be harder
and harder to propagate into the
gradient at future time stops.
Recall that recall,
this example that I showed at the
beginning,
the whole point of using recurrent
neural networks is because we wanted to
model longterm dependencies,
but if our parameters are biased to
capture short term dependencies,
even if they see the whole sequence,
there'll be by the parameters will
become biased to to predict things based
mostly on the past couple of words.
Um,
okay,
so now I'm going to go through some,
a couple methods that are used to
address this issue in practice that work
pretty well.
The first one is the choice of
activation function.
So you saw that one of the terms that
was making that product really small was
the f prime term.
I've crime is the derivative of whatever
activation function we choose to use.
Here I've plotted the derivatives of
some common activation functions.
You could see that the derivative of
hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid is always
less than one.
In fact for sigmoid is always less than
0.25
and instead we choose to use an
activation function like rarely.
It's always one above zero so that will
at least prevent the f prime terms from
shrinking the gradient.
Okay.
Another solution would be how we
initialize our weights.
If we initialize the weights from a
normal distribution,
there'll be mostly less than one and
they'll immediately strength the
gradients.
If instead we initialize the weights to
something like the identity matrix,
it will at least prevent that w term
from shrinking the product at least at
the beginning.
The next deletion is very different.
Um,
it involves actually adding a lot more
complexity to the network using a more
complex type of cell called a gated sell
rather than here rather than each node
just being that simple rnn unit that I
showed at the beginning,
we'll replace it with a much more
complicated cell.
A very common gated cell is something
called an Lstm or long short term
memory.
So like its name implies lstm cells are
able to keep memory within the cell
state unchanged for many times stuffs
this allows them to effectively model
longer term dependencies.
So I'm going to go through a very high
level overview of how lsts work,
but if you're interested,
feel free to email me or ask me
afterwards and I can direct you to some
more resources to read about.
LSTM is a lot more detail.
Okay.
All right.
So lstm basically have a three step
process.
The first step is to forget your
relevant parts of the cell state.
For example,
if we're modeling a sentence and we see
a new subject,
we might want to forget things about the
old subject because we know that future
words will be conjugated according to
the new subject.
Okay.
The next day,
the next step is an update stuff.
Here's where we actually update the cell
state to reflect the new,
the information from the new input.
In this example,
like I said,
if we've just seen a new subject,
we might want to,
this is where we actually update the
cell state with the gender or whether
the new subject is plural or singular.
Yeah.
Finally we want to output certain parts
of the cell state.
So if we've just seen a subject,
we have an idea that the next word might
be a verb.
So we'll,
I'll put information relevant to
predicting a verb like the 10th.
Each of these three steps is implemented
using a set of logic gates and the logic
gates are implemented using sigma
functions.
To give you some intuition on why Lstm
is help with the vanishing gradient
problem,
uh,
is that first the forget gate.
The first step can equivalently be
called the remember gate because there
you're choosing what to forget and what
to keep in the cell state.
The forget gate can choose to keep
information in the cell state for many,
many times steps.
There's no activation function or
anything else shrinking that
information.
The second step,
the second thing is that the cell state
is separate from what's outputted.
We're mate.
This is not true of normal recurrent
units like I showed you before in a
simple recurrent unit.
The cell state is the same thing as what
that sell outputs with an Lstm,
it has a separate cell state and it only
needs to output information relevant to
the prediction at that time stuff.
Because of this,
it can keep information in the cell
state,
which might not be relevant at this
time.
Stuff that might be relevant at a much
later time step.
So we can keep that information without
being penalized for that.
Finally,
I didn't indicate this explicitly in the
diagram,
but the way that the update step happens
is through an additive function not
through a multiplicative function.
So when we take the derivative,
there's not a huge expansion.
So now I just want to move on to going
over,
um,
some possible tasks.
So the first task is a classification.
So here we want to classify tweets as
positive,
negative or neutral.
And this task is also knowing that
sentiment analysis.
Okay?
The way that we would design a recurrent
neural network to do this is actually
not by having an output at every time
step.
We only want one output for the entire
sequence.
And so we'll take him the entire
sequence,
the entire tweet,
one word at a time.
And at the very end we'll produce an
output which will,
which will actually be a probability
distribution over possible classes where
our classes in this case would be
positive,
negative,
or neutral.
Note that the only information that is
producing the output at the end is the
final cell state.
Okay.
And so that final cell state kind of has
to summarize all of the information from
the big,
from the entire sequence into that final
cell state.
So we can imagine if we have very
complicated tweets or,
well,
I don't know if that's possible,
but very complicated paragraphs or
sentences.
We might want to create a bigger network
with more hidden states to allow that
last state to be more expressive.
The next task would be something like
music generation,
and I'll see if this will play.
Yeah,
you can kind of hear it.
Okay.
So that was music generated by an Rnn,
which is pretty cool.
And something you're actually also going
to do in the lab today.
But,
uh,
music generally you can,
an rnn can produce music because music
is just a sequence and the way that you
would,
the way that you would construct a neuro
on a recurrent neural network to do this
would be at every time point taking in a
note and producing the most likely.
Next note given the notes that you've
seen so far.
So here you would produce an output at
every time step.
The final task is machine translation.
Machine translation is interesting
because it's actually two recurrent
neural networks,
um,
side by side.
The first is an encoder.
The encoder takes as input a sentence in
a source language like English,
it.
Then there's an a decoder which produces
the same sentence in a target language
like French notice in this architecture
that the only information passed from
the encoder to the decoder is the final
cell state.
And the idea is that that final cell
state should be kind of a summary of the
entire encoder sentence.
And given that summary,
the decoder should be able to figure out
what the encoder sentence was about and
then produce the same sentence in a
different language.
You can imagine though that,
okay,
maybe this is possible for a sentence,
a really simple sentence like the dog
eats.
Maybe we can encode that in the final
cell state,
but if we had a much more complicated
sentence or a much longer sentence,
that would be very difficult to try and
summarize the whole thing and that one
cell state.
So what's typically done in practice for
machine translation is something called
a tension with attention rather than
just taking in the final cell state to
the decoder at each time step,
we take in a weighted sum of all of the
previous cell states.
So in this case we're trying to produce
the first word.
We'll take in a weighted sum of all of
the encoder states.
Most of the weight will probably be on
the first state because that's what
would be most relevant to producing the
first word.
Then when we produced the second word,
most of the weight will probably be on
the second cell state,
but we might have som on the first and
the third to try and get an idea for,
um,
the tents or the gender of this now.
And the same thing for all of the cell
states.
The way that you implement this is just
by including those weight parameters in
the weighted sum as additional
parameters that you chain using
backpropagation just like everything
else.
Okay.
So I hope that you have an idea now why
we need a different framework to model
sequences and how recurrent neural
networks can solve some of the issues
that we saw at the beginning,
um,
as well as an idea of how to them and
saw some of the vanishing gradient
problems.
Okay.
I've talked a lot about language,
but you can imagine using these exact
same neural network,
recurrent neural networks for modeling
time series or wave forms or doing other
interesting sequence prediction tasks
like predicting stock market trends or
summarizing books or articles.
Um,
and maybe you'll consider some sequence
modeling tasks for your final project.
So thank you.
[inaudible].